and if you're making last-minute dinner
plans you may have a hard time getting
in some of the titties and some in some
of the city's top spots joining me now
former arkansas governor mike huckabee
who's the host of [ __ ] of huckabee right
here on the fox news channel he's also a
former republican presidential candidate
i believe in only two things completely
the first amendment and boobs and so
once they made the decision what did you
say you believe in the first amendment
and
bwbs
boobs two things that have only never
let me down in this entire country's
history the first amendment and boobs
check this out it's a very curious
beaver
breeding those little guys are cute and
cuddly looking and the beavers i've seen
are bigger
and not yeah and they don't look as
friendly so
i don't know maybe i've seen my beavers
in the wrong place
[Laughter]
moving on
every player unless they're from the
same same household has to bring their
own tennis balls so that you don't touch
other people's tennis balls um
with your hands you can kick their balls
but you can't touch them
i'm gonna blush sorry um of course if
you're pl
if you're playing with someone in your
household you can touch those tennis
balls
uh to avoid confusion
to avoid confusion between who's balls
are whose you can use a marker like a
sharpie to mark out to put an x or put
someone's initials on them number five
takes us to an accident scene in
charlotte north carolina four
firefighters are hurt after a [ __ ]
truck a fire truck overturned on the
highway this morning hey everyone give
us a wave
yvonne
yeah she's talking footy
hold on
ktvu has just learned the names of the
four pilots who are on board the flight
they are captain sum ting wang
we too low
ho li fuk and bang deng ao please do me
i know we haven't got time to do it now
but can you just stay and do me that
sounds
like an offer i'm not gonna get again so
uh absolutely let's take a look at
birthdays and anniversaries in the
meantime happy 80th birthday to e norma
stitz uh quitman happy birthday to you
miss e norma hope you have a wonderful
day this is a big fan right here well
guess what the ipad 2 is what we're
talking about tonight well it it's still
not available yet so hold your deck cool
your jets ernie we do have more video of
event that we can show you uh it was
sent to us from apple a cannon
i don't know oh what do you do what do
you do
no there's no erasing is the thing
oh that's amazing um
tickets are only 25 it's for charity and
uh
you can get tickets online at pick a
dick pic
[Laughter]
well you're thinking about starting
peak attack
oh my goodness it got me thinking what
do you have by your bed that is long and
stabby or whatever that is going to make
a mess of someone who tries to break
into your house and and try and steal
something from your heart george do you
have something well tim's my long stabby
thing
but i used to have i used to have the
olympic torch
under the bed when i was single but yeah
now i've got tim
that's that's an excellent lucky
long-standing thing for a lot of kids
they cannot be out in these sub-zero
wind chills megan back to you all right
so if they're canceling the train does
that mean that you and i are having
another night in bed together
oh my goodness
um
i have no words yeah except that we're
going to be on youtube in a few minutes
have you ever hit anything that you've
been throwing at funnily enough i've
never willy-wagged since then
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
let's turn to weather now if you wanted
to get outside
spread your legs a little or stretch a
little today was a great day to enjoy
meteorologist craig flint here now with
your fox first forecast um
ninth anniversary and hugh janus turning
10. we've mentioned
i'm sorry
i'm sorry
it's one of those it's one of those
i totally fell for it didn't i
now we all have dogs have you ever
dressed your dog up i honestly have not
well you got a big dog that's probably
why she's larger yeah mark has a little
wiener have you ever dressed the wiener
up yeah i do he's um what are you doing
he's a actually
i had a bug there
when my son was teething he used to like
to take the big fat rubber end of my
vibrating toothbrush
and put it in his mouth on and he'd just
kind of sit there like
oh yeah that feels good that hits a spot
my gums are itchy one way to do a turkey
call is is is with this gobbler and it
has a little a little diaphragm in it
that
allows the air to vibrate you should try
that i would like to go ahead i want to
see this
[Laughter]
that just wasn't right
i know these showers are starting to die
down a bit and we are beginning to see
some showers moving into louisiana right
now southeast satellite radar composite
shows those showers remember the green
flashing you know in the dial oh yeah
sure
and i thought nothing will ever be as
cool as crystal meth pepsi
and
oh yeah
crystal pepsi yes christopher
sorry
because
people shouldn't be wearing ankle socks
just get long socks people get stuck
pull your pants down or well put your
ain't
the leg down
middle star adam driver known for the
force awakens and girls he kind of looks
like my brother too maybe that's why i
give him
you go dude all right what
all right
let's
talk about the weather police department
in california is taking an unusual
approach to catch porn pirates
red-handed porch pirates yes
[Music]
[Music]
no that's not that's
[Laughter]
championship trophy was also on display
this morning
for fans to get enough close look
at just the trophy of course let's go
back to the hose
oh that's not a terrible back of the
hoses goodness gracious to be fair
pushing it over the top of the country
is when you take a step back
is there anything else you see in this
book sam you didn't have to say that
what it's about as subtle as a
sledgehammer mate
why didn't you just oh maybe melissa she
certainly had to look up there's a lot
of detail lots of emails coming in about
um you know these hot cross buns yes i
just had a bite of georgie's bun
and
let me tell you
what
yes carl just keep talking
i know i know just keep talking don't
know where it comes from anyway i think
it's got too many bits in it georgie i
would suggest you don't have a crack at
my buns because they are very very good
buns and i won't hear anything for the
contrary the ex i've seen i'm with you
in the making okay excellent bye guys
i'm gonna go put some clothes on hold on
a second no not so fast adam let's uh
let's see uh anna let's see this is in
uh new jersey right
be nice i just want to talk to her a
little bit
milking this shot i'm just wondering uh
anna how long did it take you uh let's
see did you get undressed to drive yeah
well we saw that okay i guess we're done
where do you get all this stuff um these
you can buy and those ones i make
huh
uh no you know
the tools in your hand what did i just
make there
oh my gosh
i gotta get rid of that
it's mark here and they asked me to join
in but i've got a small white one does
that make a difference
no actually you know what i don't think
i don't actually think it's the size of
it it's actually the technique
okay thank you chris bellisario the
stilt walker i was originally going to
come in between her
legs but yeah that's not what was not
going to happen would not have made for
good tv had she fallen over so the new
mom's one regret is that she didn't get
a picture of baby william's birth
because dad was a little distracted
and that's all we have to say
she also wants to make it known that
william was born actually in the
ambulance which technically was not on
strip club property it's the ambulance
important distinction that's just such a
funny story but you know what we've all
been there you know in the basement
[Laughter]
[Music]
matt boner tiffany thiessen and tim
decay are the stars of white collar good
morning to all of you good morning
morning
that would be matt bulmer
what did i say
the deputy police chief says six
officers were killed including the
district's top [ __ ] talk [ __ ] after a
cop after the vehicle they were riding
in was sprayed with bullets three other
officers were hurt in the attack